[Musik]
also es gab zeiten januar bis juni habe
ich durch geballert wir haben also alles
ohne gebrochen gemacht wie im
privatleben hatte luisa neubau noch ist
vergleich wird vielleicht ich bin jetzt
23 als ich 20 war bin ich öfter nach
hause gekommen wenn die sonne
aufgegangen ist mein partyleben sind so
einer light-version gerade manchmal ist
super ätzend weil irgendein hantel macht
irgendwas muss ich 3000 leute anrufen
muss mit der presse sprechen muss mich
davon distanzieren und es ist nervig
natürlich weil ich gefühlt immer und
überall ein bisschen aktiv und präsent
sein muss uns alles im blick behalten
muss
bedroht wird
wie fühlt sich das an wenn auf twitter
1000 leute die ja hate dinge schreiben
an fantasien darüber wie man sich mich
vergewaltigen könnte und das ist lee
sind sie dann fühlt es sich an als würde
so dieser hass aus dem handy raus kommen
aber an der stelle war für mich total
klar okay
das müssen jetzt weitermachen das gibt
kraft ich würde eher ja
graf ich würde eher so eine art gefeiert
[Musik]
da muss man überlegen sind
die gucken gucken wie sozusagen herab
auf staaten die in das klima
offensichtlich egal ist im zweifel von
den usa oder starten auf denen das wurde
es nicht so stark auf der agenda steht
wie indien und verstecken uns
gleichzeitig dahinter oder sagen wir so
hey wir können das doch machen und
beweisen wie es geht
ich merke dass die folge dass durch das
ist nicht nur eine sache von frau merkel
aber was mich schon irritiert jetzt
gerade wo sich die frage stellt was
bleibt eigentlich und sie am ende
bewerten was mit ihr schluss signal sein
da könnte sie sagt man richtige
symphonie eine klima symphonie anstimmen
wo sie könnten ja auch mal anfangen
nicht nur fragen zu stellen
nicht nur einen finger zu zeigen und
verantwortung übernehmen also meine
wahrnehmung gibt es bisher sagen ein
politisches mandat nur eine von ganz
ganz viele möglichkeiten verantwortung
zu übernehmen zum beispiel finde ich
auch dass wir als ob die bislang gerade
relativ viel verantwortung dafür tragen
eine debatte zu initiieren am laufen zu
halten eine agenda zu setzen den finger
in die wunde legen das eine sache
lösungen anzubieten andere ich würde es
nicht kategorisch ausschließen
irgendwann politischer verantwortung zu
übernehmen
aber jetzt gerade in den nächsten 25
jahren kommt es überhaupt nicht in frage
[Musik]
wir waren schon arbeiten sie 70 und 85
ich probiere sechs stunden zu schlafen
mindestens und das klappt oft genug
ich hab schon gemerkt dieses jahr ich
habe zwei verhalten bekommen hier weil
das ist ganz kritisch also ich finde
sozusagen altern ist ja ein mega das
privileg einer alten ist was so schön
ist und hier habe ich muss ja nicht mit
23 gleich tun
das kann ich nicht machen mit 30
sich zeit nehmen zusammen mit guten
freunden wir zu trinken das ist als
sowas ist wie urlaub
ich bin kein biertrinker deswegen weiß
ich dass max und ich hab es ein erlebnis
ein ereignis gesagt haben dass man es
mit einer faust das verrichtet was freut
sich wenn ich ganz legte sehr und
probleme und herausforderungen der
möchte ich verstehen wie sie
funktionieren und dann stelle ich mich
jetzt welt sind überlegte was machen wir
jetzt und dann schreib einfach fest das
ganze von dem was ich mache einfach ganz
viel spaß macht mache das gerne
immerhin 25 30 jahren zurückblickt dann
sagt man die lose erneuerung das war
doch die die sie was
dabei war als wir angefangen haben die
klimakrise ernst zu nehmen